au Kazakhstan et à Madagascar il y a une
loi qui a été votée pour castrer les
pédophiles cette loi vise à protéger les
enfants qui sont de plus en plus victime
de viol dans ce pays la castration
castration physique sera alors appliquée
dans les cas les plus graves évitant
toute récidive trouvez-vous que cette
loi va trop loin oui non regardez petit
recap chaque année en France on dénombre
pas moins de 20000 plaintes pour abus
sexuel sur mineur une affaire de
pédophilie hors norme 26 victimes alors
pour tenter d'enrayer ces actes
pédophiles certains se montrent
favoraable à une mesure radicale castrer
les prédateurs sexuels la barbarie sur
la barbarie oui je remets de la barbarie
sur de la barbarie c'est comme ça c'est
réglé déjà adopté dans plusieurs pays le
Kazakhstan et Madagascar viennent
d'approuver une loi permettant d'avoir
recours à la castration chimique et même
chirurgicale dans certains cas pour
protéger les enfants des violeurs un
acte qui serait donc définitif alors le
Kazakhstan et Madagascar vote une loi
pour castrer les pédophiles
comprenez-vous cette
décision euh bien sûr qu'on comprend moi
je comprends cette décision totalement
oui je comprend oui je comprends cette
décision bien sûr Gill Verdez la
comprend pas comme d'habitude Gill
Verdez encore une fois voilà la
politique la politique de du laxisme
mais moi je suis complètement d'accord
et pas aller plus loin pas aller plus
loin oui ah oui la pédophilie c'est une
maladie donc il faut pouvoir la traiter
il y a certains pays où les gens veulent
tuer les pédophiles où ils pensent que
quelqu'un qui est pédophile ne doit n'a
pas de place dans la société doit être
mort donc si on peut les traiter leur
permettre de vivre une vie à peu près
normal et calmer leur pulsion infamme
évidemment qu'il faut le faire et pardon
mais il faut surtout penser avant tout
aux enfants et si on peut empêcher les
enfants d'être victime de ces monstres
évidemment qu'il faut les casser je vois
même pas pourquoi il y a des personnes
qui se disent qu'onfin je vois des noms
je comprends pas pouroi il va pas il
vont pas beaucoup parler si il vont
parler quand même ils vont être chiants
oui JAC moi je me souviens
[Rires]
d'unonnu non mais je me souviens d'un
reportage qu'on avait fait en Floride
sur un village des pédophiles ça existe
aux États-Unis et c'était très très
impressionnant parce que tous disent
qu'ils veulent être soignés donc je
comprends même pas qu'on puisse se poser
la question aujourd'hui il y a des
moyens de castration chimique qui sont
momentanés il s'agit pas de castrer la
personne à vie il y a deux types de
castration il a la castration par cachet
c'est par cachet de les deux de les
deuxux dire chirurgical et par cachet
très bien mais là moi je pense que déjà
appliquer la castration chimique qui
existe en France déjà mais de
l'appliquer un peu plus matiquement sur
des gens qui demandent à à pouvoir être
soignés je pense que voilà c'est c'est
c'est sur un
Mo j'a g verd quce qu' ve alors déjà la
castration physique on est d'accord en
France c'est interdit ok la castration
chimique en France c'est un médecin qui
peut voilà mais moi je suis contre je
suis contre la castration physique parce
que c'est l'amputation du corps humain
on est d'accord alors ok d'un pédophile
mais après on s'arrêtera où c'est-à-dire
qu'on on pourra couper la main à un
voleur on pour ça n'a rien à voir mais
pédophile pédophile pour moi ça part
pour moi pour moi pédophile il doit être
il doit pour moi pour moi pour moi
pédophile c'est terminé pédophile pour
moi c'est terminé il sort terminé il
sort de la société c'est
finiou
Mo faire fa tu vas laisser en prison ils
vontortir 10 ans après tu as bien vu les
récidifs moi j'ai pas de j'ai pas de
pitié moi j'ai pas de Mo plus
pi les écoutesen fonctionne ils sont
toujours dans la France du passé j'ai
pas de pitié j'ai pas de pardon
quelqu pour un enfant c'est quelqu'un
qui se sort de la soci que tu fais pour
un enfant avoir une érection pour un
enfant je ne veux pas te voir en face de
moi j'ai pas de pié j'ai pas mais la
pulion ils vont la faire autrement ils
vont la faire autrement ils utiliseront
pas leur sexe
il tu es encore à côté de la PLA oui
peut-êtreon est en train de dire c'est
est-ce qu'on les met est-ce qu'on les
met hors des toit de nuir ou pas on s'en
fout
oness on s fout pas tu comprend rien la
question c'est pas c'est ce que dit Ron
il est en train de dire ils sont il par
eux qui décid de ça les pédophiles quand
ils s'attaquent aux enfant c'est eux qui
décident de se sortir de la société si
maintenant ils ont pris des mesures à
Madagascar pour essayer un truc pour se
protéger leurs enfants à eux moi je suis
d'accord avec eux moi personnellement je
suis d'accord avec eux parce que moi
demain tu me mets un mec tu me dis que
c'est un pédophile je ne veux pas qu'il
me parle je même s'il a purgé sa peine
même si tu me dis regarde il est gentil
maintenant il fait des
aidestenant parle pas ne me parle pas je
veux pas te voir je veux pas t'entendre
je veux pas que tu me touches je veux
pas être à faire la queue au supermarché
derrière
toi en train de vous dire pour expquer
ver et ben je suis pas on n pas les deux
seuls bon voilà le prof
d'histoireil
PLA tais-toi 2 secondes s'il te plaît r
merci juste pour vous expliquer les
chéris c'est pas du tout la question en
fait là c'est juste nous ce qu'on veut
savoir c'est pas vous allez nous dire
oui mais ça marche pas less c'est pas ça
on veut trouver des solutions VO nous je
vous le dis pour que terminer puisque là
je vois plein de gens sur les réseaux
qui disent il faut aller encore plus
loin et
cetera les droits de l'homme moi ça me
choque parce que je pense aussi au droit
de l'enfant un enfant il a le droit de
pas avir quelqu'un qui va violer coin de
rue et alors soit on peut continuer à
être hypocrite à pleurer un viol
d'enfant on pleure tous mais on dit ah
bah non bah ça marche pas puis c'est
cruel c'est inhumain quand même de faire
ça à quelqu'un je suis désolé qui est
cruel et inhumain c'est de violer un
enfant il y a pas de a rien il y a pas
d'argument làdessus on a des moyens ça
marche peut-être pas dans 100 % des cas
mais il y a des moyens qui exist on a
aucune hésitation à voir avec ces gens-l
je suis désolé ou alors on continue à
pleurer à chaque fois et on ne fait rien
parce que il y a la loi parce qu'il y a
les droits de l'homme et vous voyez où
on arrive avec les droits de l'homm en
ce moment dans tous les domaines
excusez-moi les droits de et justement
vous qui êtes si clément avec les
pédophiles en invoquant les droits de
l'homme en disant oui dro tu peux pas
invquer droit dehomme quand tu parles de
ça là tu vas pouvoir sauver des
pédophiles puisque il y a un cas où ça
peut les sauver on peut tolérer c'est un
cas où un mec qui n'est jamais passé à
l'acte va voir un MDEC ou je sais pas
quoi dit excusez-moi je crois que j'ai
un problème je crois que je suis malade
je suis attiré par les enfants je veux
être guéri maintenant avant de passer à
l'acte et là on peut sauver peut-être
des pédophiles et les empêcher de per à
l'acte donc si vous voulez être clément
avec les pédophiles castrezles mais ne
cautionnez pas ce qu'ils font ne
diminuez pas la gravité de de leurs
actes en disant oui mais les droit de
l'homme il faut pas
les aucun simplement que cette cette
possibilité là qui existe par ailleurs
en France déjà d'abord c'est pas un
médecin c'est pas un just qui l' prend
c'est médecin
et par
ailleurs ce qu'on te dit c'est que tu as
10 % seulement de chance que ça puisse
fonctionner et que donc si on va croire
qu'on a une sorte d'immunité et qu'en
fait les mecs vont être dans la nature
parce qu'ils seront castrés qu'on sera
très content qu'ils sont castrés et en
fait ils vont prendre des outils des
machins des trucs et ils continueront à
faire dansine làdessus dans un instant
20h17 on est en direct touche merci
d'être là qu'est-ce qu'il a pris pendant
la
pub vous auriez dû être là oh là là là
là non mais Gilles Verdez il nous a
sorti des exemples je vous jure mais
mais c'est pas je sais pas où vit ce
gars c'est un truc de fou je ne sais pas
où vit Gilles Verdez je ne sais pas ce
que fait Gilles Verdez je ne sais pas
dans quel monde veut vivre Gill Verdez
mais Gill Verdez est dans le monde de
l'échec et je le redis encore pour moi
les gars pédophile pour moi c'est
terminé terminé terminé termin hors de
la société terminé terminé c'est fini on
veut plus les voir terminé merci au
revoir terminé il faut les castrer selon
vous ouais c'est ça non mais c'est
prison trou fa trouvez la solution mais
plus les voir terminé merci au revoir
voilà fini ou si le problème c'est de ne
plus les voir on les enfer ma vie
éventuellement mais les droits de
l'homme c'est non non les droit on les
enfer ma vie les droits de l'homme c'est
précisément la protection du cor humain
rien n non mais rien nous différencier
de Barbar si on se met à tuer les gens
si on se met à les castrer c'est
l'honneur de la France les droits de
l'homme qu me VI vas le seul martière
qu'il y a ici c'est ta coiffure
frre c'est ton coeur le seul mar
[Applaudissements]
c'est ton coiffeur
frère c'est quelqu' qui est malade il
demande luiême à être
soigné peut être un mois ça peut être de
mois ça peut être 3 mois c'est momentané
la personne retrouve mal ça va l'cher de
tu les question
mais vous avez toujours des
contreexemplessum exceptionnel
qu'onutilise pas les les moyens qui sont
qui sont à notre disposition donc c'est
ça le truc c'est que tu as la
possibilité aujourd'hui de pouvoir
traiter des gens qui sont malades qui le
demandent pour un mois pour 2 mois pour
3 mois c'est encadré par M
oé Patricia la secrétaire de direction
s'il vous
plaît pour moi la castration ça su pas
pour moi c'est peine de mort ah d'accord
quand même directement allez non il y a
plein de gens qui pensent comm même oui
ou ou mais on peut pas le dire a un cas
il y a un cas où le nom est viable c'est
le cas où on dit à mon sens c'est le cas
où on dit castrer les pédophiles c'est
quelque part les aider à à mieux vivre
et aller mieux est-ce qu'il méritent
d'être aidés je ne sais pas il y a plein
de gens qui pensent qu' doivent au moins
être enfermés à vie voir pire comme a
dit Polska et il y a plein de gens qui
pensent quand même non mais la peine de
mort a été abolie on va pas
revenir s vous PLT s'il vous plaît
laissez-moi parler oh qu'est-ce qu'il a
là garcimort
là qu'est-ce qu' droit de l'homme
justement c'est ce que c'est ce que
pardon merci oui non je voulais
simplement rappeler le cas de Francis HM
qui qui justement était dans
l'incapacité d'assouvir ses fantasmes et
ben il a tué ses victimes
ou comme raisonn il va mieux le violer
par tu peux écouter ce que je t'explique
c'est que raison vous le présentez comme
la panassée en disant que ça va résoudre
le problème r dire c'est encadré par des
mécadr
les deux les deux journalistes là je
peux plus les journalistes les
journalistes c'est insupportable ça
croit toujours que ça a raison c'est
insupportable alors que ça n'a jamais
raison de rien ça n'a jamais fait
avancer quoi que ce soit donc les
Chéries je vais vous dire la question là
elle elle est pas bonne en fait voilà
pour moi c'est voilà c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment la parce que Ben av rentrer
dans les trucs ça marche ça marche pas
de nuir à vie en fait exactement voilà
voilà qu'est-ce qui c'est qu'est-ce qui
c'est qui oui bah voilà je dis oui alors
allez-y bébé non mais non mais en fait
moi je suis très embêté parce qu'en fait
j'ai pas j'ai pas de réponse comme vous
oui et non je trouve que c'est très
compliqué d'abord ok j'écarte le côté
non mais oui merci Jacques merci de me
faire découvrir le concept mais en tu
mets non puis en fait tu vas j'exlique
pourquoi non d'abord j'écarte le côté
psychologue puisqueeffectivement ok je
suis d'accord argument on on en a marre
des psychologues qui disent oui ou les
psychiatres qui disent oui mais ça
marche pas très bien ça ok j'écarte ça
j'écarte le côté droit d'umain
puisqu'ils disent ouais c'est une loi
cruelle inhumaine et dégradante ça aussi
je suis d'accord avec toi Daniel
j'écarte ça j'écarte l'argument
totalement fallacieux et Malonn
intuellement Guillaume qui dit oui tu es
pas du côté des victimes je suis
toujours du côté des victimes donc je
suis côté des enfants mais malgré tout
quand je vois la liste des pays qui
mettent cette C cette chose en vigueur
c'est la Pologne pardon c'est le
Kazakhstan et c'est Madagascar et
bizarrement c'est des pays qui toujours
traque et chasse les homosexuels donc je
ne voudrais pas non ça rien à
voir je voudrais juste pas qu'on soit
dans des pays aussi par ailleurs qui
fasse un lien forcément pédophilie ou
ou voir le sondage le
sondage sondage regardez oui a 92,8 % il
a dit quoi Gill Verdez non comme
d'habitude voilà le génie toujours non
mais lui sans déconnerii tu imagin tu
l'as tu en a match qui donne les les
scores pour les matchs c'est le
nostradabus du P à chaque fois qu'on a
des des des de pédophile vous pensez
vraiment que les gens sont mal à chaque
fois qu'il y a des histoires de
pédophiles qui sortent au grand jour
dans les médias pour vous les gens vous
pensez vraiment sont malad
quand quand tu as une excitation
sexuelle et une envie sexuelle pour un
GAM le mode de fonctionnement quand ils
attrapent les enfants quand ils essayent
d'effacer les traces quand ils essaient
de se protéger quand ils essayent de
leur manipulation avec la justice quand
ils sont interrogés par par la policier
vous pensez vraiment qu'ils sont mal moi
je vais te dire une chose pour moi ils
sont pas malades c'est ils sont pas
malades pour moi ces gens-là vous vous
pensez qu'ils sont malades ils sont ils
sont peut-être dingues dans dans la
dinguerie qu'ils font mais ils sont pas
malades n'alz pas me dire faut les
soigner il y a pas à les soigner moi je
soigne les vrais malades moi ceux qui
sont vraiment malades en France je les
soigne pour moi lui je soig pas
moi voà mer malade c'est bon merci
c'eston tiens on va parler d'un autre
génie tiens après ti s'il vous plaît
après tirardisson on va parler d'un
autre génie euh